[Music]
if you've ever browsed self-improvement
forums like on reddit then you'll often
come across some pretty good advice some
pretty questionable stuff - no doubt but
every once in a while there's a little
nugget of wisdom that sticks with you
and one of my favorites of all time is
this do your future self favors
it's simple effective but a lot of us
don't do it very often but that's dumb
because if you think about it you
currently are your past selves future
self don't you wish your past self did
some more things for you like save some
more money or kept up with the laundry
so that you'd have some clean clothes to
wear today if past you could have just
buckled up dealt with a little bit of
discomfort and took care of business
then your current life would be a lot
better because of it but for a lot of us
this rarely happens because we don't
actually think of our future self as the
same person in fact studies have shown
that when thinking of our future self
the same part of the brain lights up
that does when we think of other people
so our brain literally processes the
idea of our future self like some other
more motivated person who doesn't mind
taking care of all the little crap we
don't currently want to deal with never
really cluing in to the fact that soon
enough this imaginary future life will
eventually just be our life so if you
don't want the things in your life to
get progressively worse stop doing that
stop shooting yourself in the foot and
start getting things done now start
doing things right now that you know you
should do even little things if your
garbage is full take out the garbage if
you have an annoying email you have to
write write it when that one little
errand you have to run pops into your
mind again go do it because this list of
responsibilities you have isn't actually
endless you're just making an endless by
leaving it to your future self all the
time when you start dealing with tasks
the minute they pop into your head then
you won't have to deal with them ever
again and once you finally complete that
list why stop there do your future self
some more favors why not choose the
outfit you're gonna wear tomorrow or
iron all your dress shirts so that when
you need to go run off to a job
interview randomly and unpredictably
you'll be good to go no sweat he'll next
time you buy a chocolate bar buy another
one and keep it in your cupboard for
when future you has a really bad day and
you really just needs a chocolate bar or
something to lighten up the spirits you
get the idea
make life awesome for future you because
eventually that'll just be you by
constantly
doing your future self favors you're
setting yourself up for success and
gradually trending your life in an
upward direction if you liked this video
hit that like button if you like videos
like these in general hit that subscribe
button also leave a comment because I
respond to every comment
I love seeing comments and just
discussion in general is great for the
channel and I want to hear from you it's
a win win win also follow me on
Instagram Facebook and Twitter
there are links in the description for
all those things also consider
supporting me on patreon you'll have
access to my weekly video series that I
post just on patreon also if you want to
see me get slapped in the face by my
roommate in slow motion
after I yell out your username that's
also a patreon reward so check it out
either way I hope you have an awesome
day thanks for watching remember to
leave a comment and I'll catch you in
the next video